お菓子剣士キャンペーン始めて2ヶ月ほど去ったんですけどもなんだろうかねあんまり
辛くないですわかんない夏になるとめっちゃ食べたくなるかもしれないけどでもお花
じゃなくてもお前は意外とイケるぞって本当に対象のお菓子騎士しますと言った
4日間くらいはすごく辛かったんですけど3日4日ぐらいになるともう本当にね傾いの
ことを考えずにすみますね全然いけるとはご飯で何でこんな事やったら
よくわかんないんですけどおかしくはなくても全然いけますよ実際ね昔元してそのず
おいしいメシを食えばいいかな
昔警視キャンペーン
結構余裕です日記秒まではできなくなった気がするな
たぶんできてないと思う握りというか肌荒れがメス暗くなった気がするしたと
おっしゃったので不足の方の挑戦青が良くなったのと最近よく細くなってるんですよ
体重は変わってないんですけど顔のこの前よりちょっとシュッとしてる気がします
わかんないけどねあいつはけっこうよくなったちょっと良かったらぜひやってみて
ください意外という宝おかし記事
でも余裕で行けますでなまぁ想像の話をするよなぜ僕がそもそも菓子継承したかと言え
ますがビューを言いましょうてその理由に基づいておかしいとは何なのかその定義次は
僕は曖昧にしていた
今までお母さんの定義続きをしっかりした上で今後のキャンペーンを続けていこうと
思ってる今日とりあえずそのおかあステージにした理由車を買っての締結月報まず話で
ございます
お菓子を記事にしたリーダー
んですけども簡単にいうとまあごとくの方も多いと思うんですけど
主食がお菓子だったんですよまじでもう夜ご飯とかお昼ご飯がおかしいだけの時もある
し辺野古の里に箱食う時もあった
あと食べたくなってきちゃった訳は音を試食を動かせにするのはまずいかなと体が
ぶっ壊れるんだと思ってやめました
お菓子まあ冒にはねその砂糖がたくさん入ってたりな甘味料とかねちょっとそういうの
がたくさんあるんでさぁ等のみを摂取するみたいな完全すごい悪いからに悪いって感じ
なんでやめてました糖尿病とかになるかもしれないからねてガーゼ理由である
ますつまり俺の中のお菓子の定義は砂糖の量俺はそんな気がする
砂糖の量が非常に多くてねなんかこうね何か甘いおかしいよねこっちいいは置かず本当
に何の話をして佐藤が行為等て気に入ってる甘いと泉などは佐藤だねある程度入ってた
お菓子って言ってたらそれはもう婚活になりますよアイスもそうですしレッドブルとか
も全然っていうのは全部犯すんです
僕の中ではねそこで今回ですよ私のこの定義に基づいた上で犯すとは見なされないよう
にチョコレートを食べる方法はないかと思いまして先日なんかチョコレートを緊急して
いるチョコレート君というお方にお会いしまして相談したんですけどこれはまあ大丈夫
だこんなつお礼じゃなくていいよみたいなをチョコレートちょっと紹介してみいただい
たのでちょっと買ってしまいますもうちょっと空いてるんですけどこっちで
ですドア描くリオル100というチョコレートですみんなこれは動かすじゃない
いや
まあ違うシェアそちらまずオファーね定義北署定義を取りでございます今の局がある
まで説明をしましょうどう肉利用の100というチョコレート砂糖が入っておりません
なんかを100%お菓子ちん子にした new に基づくを課すという記事の中にこれ
は含まれない例外タイプですなので僕の中で ok だしてチョコレート君も ok
って言っちゃったので ok ですこのサイズで800円です誰か
はいじゃあまでそんなめちゃくちゃそこでとクリエイティブでもないか
もうなんかを日付しすぎてもそういう概念はないかとこれは何かも仕方ないか食ってろ
ぐらいの感じで買いましたぜそういうチョコレート聞いたいることがないんで
あっはこれやな液晶しクリオロ違いを0.01%以下の品種
マジでっていうの世界で0.01パーセントしかねすごいですよ全部カカオで作られて
いますつまり
チョコレートではありませんた母ですほらぼくのなかったセーフなんですよ
砂糖が入ってない2カ月ぶりに坪鈴と食べてみます0.01%だよ魔って本当にそんな
低いか
がちだったまあ想像方をっていうものは何かって話ししましょう香川の健康効果が
ちょっとなんかがありまして体調
整える効果リラックス効果便秘を解消する効果動脈硬化を予防する効果があるみたい
です
半蔵日に来ればよかった開けますよ
公営サイズね世界で0.01%チョコレートですからね
これっかーこれが墓は100%のチョコレートですツッコミとかによるとすごい
おいしいって書いてありました佐藤も使ってなくてか買うだけなのにおいしいって言っ
てたんだよねもう食わざるを得んと思ってねっ
早速いただきます大丈夫佐藤入ってないんだろうめっちゃいい匂いするんだけど怖い
なぁ佐藤本当に入ってないかな
大丈夫これ本当にだ
ジョブのですかいただきます
思った
wh
あっ晴れチョコレートじゃないかあぁ
風味は二子インスはチョコレートのすごいおいしい風味やするんですけどあのお菓子の
女じゃない感じうんやつがいいんですけどちょっと僕じゃないかな
このチョコの甘い風味は感じがありますがあばあさんは一切ございません
ちょっと高いんですけどいる方は是非買ってみてくださいじゃあな
me
ません
wh